[Music]
hi guys
it's quinn here the youtube algorithm
has a strange will of its own
and sometimes it forgets to remind
people about my channel
if you appreciate the content you can
help out by clicking the like button
dune has long been regarded as one of
the greatest and most
influential science fiction series
everything from star wars to star trek
to the expanse
has in some way been inspired by the
classic work by frank herbert
dune focuses on the economic and
socio-political systems revolving around
the planet arrakis
the only planet in the empire where the
precious spice melange can be found
arrakis also known as dune falls under
the feetum of the noble house
atreides which consists of the duke lato
his mini jesuit concubine jessica
and the 15 year old son paul the native
people of arrakis are called the fremen
who were once many centuries ago known
as the zensuni wanderers
the books indicated that the fremen are
a diverse group which picked up
genes of many different humans during
their migrations from planet to planet
before settling on dune
much of frimen culture as described in
the books
is inspired by real world buddhist and
islamic traditions
the main plot of the first dune book is
centered around paul atreide's use
of the fremen to avenge the fall of
house atreides
and gain control of the imperial throne
now i won't be explaining the entire
plot line of the dune saga
i mean that would take several hour long
videos and who has time for that
though dune is considered one of the
most influential science fiction sagas
ever it's not without controversy it has
been argued by some that dune is one of
the prime examples
of the white savior trope now i've
addressed this in
the past to some degree see this video
here i did responding to an article
written by noah burt lasky
which accused paul tradies of being
quote a mighty whitey
but i've never dived entirely into the
subject
in this video we will explore the
historical context of the white savior
trope
dissect how race is viewed in the dune
saga and determine once and for all
whether or not dune is an example of
this trope
we will start with the basics what is a
mighty whitey
in 1899 rudyard kipling yeah that's his
real name
wrote a poem titled the white man's
burden
the poem is about the
philippine-american war and the poem
kipling strongly encourages the united
states to assume control of the
philippines
and its people making it a colony of the
united states
now i'm going to read a bit of this poem
but warning
it's racist as [ __ ] take up the white
man's burden
send forth the best ye breed go send
your sons to
exile to serve your captives need to
wait in heavy harness
on fluttered folk and wild your new
caught sullen peoples
half devil and half child yikes
yes he just called filipino people devil
children
in the poem kipling is basically telling
other white people to just suck it up
and go help the savages
because they obviously can't do it
themselves and they need the white man
to tell them how it's done
take up the white man's burden the
savage wars of peace
fill full the mouth of famine and bid
the sickness cease
and when your goal is nearest the in for
others sought
watch sloth and heathen folly bring all
your hopes to naught
bid the sickness cease eh i wonder if
kipling is aware that 90 percent of
native americans died
of diseases brought over to the americas
by white europeans
jared diamond points this out in his
book guns germs and steel
which we will talk about more in just a
second but i don't need to read any more
of kipling's poem for now
you can read the whole thing if you want
it's pretty short
in the poem kipling portrays the white
man as a glowing force
for good that only wants to help the
world
but it's just so hard because of those
goddamn devil children
in all seriousness kipling obviously has
some sort of white
superiority complex and is in fact
presenting racist ideas in this poem
but as many of you know this kind of
thinking was not uncommon in the 19th
century
in this poem kipling expresses the same
ideological sentiment
which was found in the manifest destiny
philosophy of that century
manifest destiny is essentially when the
united states decided that it was its
destiny to expand its empire
this philosophy along with
continentalism the belief that the u.s
would eventually encompass all of north
america
led to the louisiana purchase of 1803
which essentially doubled the size of
the united states
from there the united states continued
to expand westward with the annexing of
texas in 1845
a treaty with great britain in 1846 in
which the us acquired the oregon
territory
and the mexican session of 1848 after
25 000 mexicans including 1 000
civilians
had been killed during the
mexican-american war
during the trail of tears which took
place between 1830 and 1850
more than 100 000 native americans
including thousands of their black
slaves
were displaced from their lands
thousands died of exposure
famine and disease before arriving at
the reservations
the united states government had
designated for them
all of this happened in part because of
the us's philosophy
of manifest destiny and the us's desire
for westward expansion
so this idea that the white man is
somehow fated to acquire new lands
and make them in their own image is not
new it was a very real belief
that many people who were considered
respectable once had
but why was this idea so common
in 1997 anthropologist and historian
jarrett diamond published his book
titled guns germs and steel which we
mentioned earlier
the book has been widely praised and won
the aventis prize for best science book
in 1998
as well as a pulitzer prize for
non-fiction the book is applauded for
asking what was at the time considered
to be an incredibly original question
why did europeans constantly triumph in
conquest of other groups
of people why is it that africans
aboriginal australians and native
americans were not the ones who enslaved
or exterminated the europeans
in 1997 james shreve wrote this of
diamond's book
in a new york times article perhaps it
had never been
posed in quite the same terms before
because the answer was assumed to be
obvious
the europeans triumphed because they
were technologically and politically
superior to the indigenous populations
they encountered left to ferment
unexamined
this assumption led to the corollary
belief most
often unconsciously held that european
hegemony
had something to do with the europeans
and nate superiority as people
the success of european colonization had
nothing to do with their racial
superiority
and everything to do with accidents of
circumstance
europeans quite simply had resources
africans did not
which placed them on a technological
trajectory that more primitive
civilizations could not defend against
jared diamond writes in his book guns
germs and steel
in short europe's colonization of africa
had nothing to do with differences
between european and african peoples
themselves
as white racist assume rather it was due
to accidents of geography and
biogeography in particular
to the continent's different areas axes
and suites of wild plants
and animal species that is the different
historical trajectories of africa and
europe stem ultimately from differences
in real estate so that explains where
these ideas come from
and of course these ideas leaked into
the literature that was being produced
by those who held these beliefs whether
subconscious
or otherwise the white savior trope is
extremely
common even till this day but circling
back around to the main topic of this
video
the answer is actually more nuanced than
you may think but before we get to that
we still got a little bit more to go
over first
we have to talk about the man himself
frank herbert
frank herbert was born on october 8th
1920 in tacoma washington when frank
herbert was nine years old the great
depression hit
he lived there with his parents elene
mccarthy herbert and frank patrick
herbert senior
until 1938 when he ran away to live with
his aunt and uncle in oregon after
working as a photographer
during world war ii frank herbert went
to study at the university of washington
there he met his second wife beverly ann
stewart during a creative writing class
frank herbert didn't graduate college
but became interested in the works of
young heidegger and freud after moving
to california in 1949
it was around the same time that he was
also introduced to the ideas of zen
buddhism
before frank herbert ever wrote science
fiction he had familiarized himself with
the works of jack vance
robert heinlein and h.g wells herbert's
first ever science fiction story was
published in a magazine
in 1954. herbert continued to write
stories throughout the decade
but was only moderately successful it
was in 1959 that frank herbert began
researching the sand dunes of oregon
for a magazine article soon he realized
that he had far
more material than a simple magazine
article needed
his research became the seed for dune
he spent the next six years researching
and writing the book
dune would be full of themes including
but not limited to
sociology and how unconscious human
instinct
affects our behavior and thus the
societies we live in
human survival and evolution ecological
systems in the short and long term
and most importantly humankind's
tendency to be attracted to
and fall in line behind leaders who
possess charismatic traits
a danger in which he felt led to many
problems in society
when considering frank herbert's
political leanings i get the sense that
he disliked politics in general
according to frank herbert power
attracts the corruptable
and we should be suspected anyone who
seeks it out
frank herbert saw the necessity of
government but did not deny the inherent
problems with all political systems that
we
as human society had not yet solved
frank herbert envisioned a galactic
society of humans
still struggling with these issues frank
herbert rarely ever mentions race
in any of his writings or books that i
can seem to locate
his interests seem to mostly revolve
around these social and political
aspects of human society
in regard to the relationship between
the leaders of society
and those they rule not specific to race
okay so that was a look at frank
herbert's background as well as the
history of how he came to be the author
of the dune series
now considering all of what we just
learned let's take a look at how
race is handled in dune
in the real world race is actually not a
biologically understood term
modern science actually considers racial
categories to be weak
proxies for genetic diversity a race is
actually a grouping of humans based on
physical
and social qualities they share which
are seen as distinct by their society
the duke latos skin is described
repeatedly as dark and
olive she looked at his tallness
at the dark skin that made her think of
olive groves
and golden sun on blue waters behind
them came a tall man
hawk-faced dark of skin and hair he wore
a jabba cloak
with the atreides crest at the breast
and wore it in a way that betrayed his
unfamiliarity with the garment
the duke was tall olive skin his thin
face held harsh angles warmed only by
deep grays
the name atreides indicates that the
atreides can trace their ancestry all
the way to ancient greece
but considering that it's been at least
20 000 years
since house atreides resided in greece i
think it's pretty fair to say
that this likely doesn't say much about
what race they are
especially when you consider that the
benny desert sisterhood
has been tampering with the atreides
bloodline for thousands of years
mixing their genes with those of other
humans in order to acquire certain
traits
other than that if you take a look at
the real-life modern world
mixed-race babies are more common than
ever
everyone's genes are mixing i imagine
that by the year 10
000 ag everyone would look like some
version of the future people from that
episode of south park
which is basically tan or olive and by
the way
the skin of characters is described as
no other way
than olive throughout the entire book
no one is referred to as white or as any
other race for that matter
the only other character that is
distinguished other than lato being dark
olive is chani
the character chani who becomes the love
interest of paul
is described as having pale olive skin
her skin was pale olive dark hair swept
back from her high forehead
throwing emphasis on sharp cheekbones
and aqualine nose between
the dense darkness of her eyes shawnee
is a frim and descent
and it seems likely given zensuni
history that the freeman would have many
varying skin tones
chany is the only friman in the book
that is specifically stated to have
pale olive skin the only other person
whose skin tone is described is hera
the friend and wife of james her skin is
simply stated to be olive
i don't think that race as thought of
today
really matters anymore in frank
herbert's universe
no one really cares about skin tone in
this society
humanity is sufficiently mixed to the
point where race has
changed significantly the tslaylaksu are
far more different from others in the
dune imperium
than any real human races currently
living on earth
are different from each other when you
live in a universe where there are
guild navigators with webbed hands and
feet who float in tanks
and elf like clay laksu with
shape-shifting minions
then skin tone becomes less significant
race in dune is only mentioned as a
group for all humans
paul often thinks about the race as in
the human race in the book
the race knows its own mortality and
fear stagnation of its heredity
it is in the bloodstream the urge to
mingle genetic strains without plan
paul also mentions a race consciousness
that he feels
in essence paul can sense the flowing of
all human events around him
he is the fulcrum by which all human
fate turns
the concept of race and dune is
all-encompassing
in this viewpoint only the human race
exists
part 4 is dune a white savior story
so let's get into the meat and potatoes
of this video
is dune a white savior story we've
discussed what the white savior trope
is and its historical context and we've
discussed how
race is viewed in the dune saga but
there's something here that actually
matters much more than the potential
race of any character
regardless of skin color dupleto is a
member of the aristocracy
and so is his son paul who would
eventually come to rule the frimen
i think that looking at this story in
terms of race is actually a quite
shallow perspective
the actual conflict of the dune saga is
clearly between the elite ruling class
and those they manipulated and oppressed
regardless of paul atreides's race
what he did was ultimately strip the
freemen of their wealth
their power and their culture all at
once the freeman fell
under the control of the imperial house
atreides and they were withered down to
a pale
shadow of what they once were
so let's just say for a second that dune
is in fact
meant to portray the white savior trope
well it's not exactly the best
representative of the trope now
is it but paul atreides does in fact
share one trope with those who followed
manifest destiny
paul had no delusions of racial
superiority towards the freemen
but like those who believe the manifest
destiny
paul did not choose to help the freeman
out of his
innate goodness he used them as a
resource for his
own goals at their detriment and
at the detriment of billions of others i
might add
again this harkens back to frank
herbert's desire to show how the
aristocratic class
manipulates those beneath them paul was
forced to act out of necessity
but he manipulated the freeman to
horrifying ends nonetheless
white savior stories depict the white
savior as just that
a savior a hero who does good and leaves
the people he saves to a better life
we've discussed several times on this
channel how paul is not the hero of dune
and you can find one of those videos
here bottom line
frank herbert explicitly stated that he
wrote the dune saga specifically to
teach people
not to put their faith in charismatic
leaders whether they are white or black
before we get to the conclusion of this
video a quick
behind the scenes story about the
creation of this video
i'm going to be real with you guys
there's a reason i decided to make this
vid
well beyond addressing annoying hot
takes about dune online
i recently took one of those dna tests
basically just out of curiosity but the
results i got were pretty interesting
so 91.4 sub-saharan african
genetics originating in nigeria ghana
liberia and golia now all of this makes
sense because
i'm black and people from those places
in the world are considered
black but i'm also almost eight percent
european
six percent of my dna is from the uk and
two percent can be traced somewhere in
europe
i also have small amounts of native
american and south east asian dna now i
didn't expect to discover
any of this but somehow it got me
thinking about dune
naturally humans mix the more connected
the world becomes the more humans mix
the bini jesuit engaged in deliberate
manipulation of human breeding
they chose specific bloodlines for
specific traits
mixing and matching the great houses in
order to achieve perfect balance
again the benny desert worked in service
of the race
he remained silent thinking like the
seed he was
thinking with the race consciousness he
had first experienced as terrible
purpose
he had found that he could no longer
hate the benny jesuit
or the emperor or even the harkonnens
they were all caught up in the need of
their race to renew its scattered
inheritance
to cross and mingle and infuse their
bloodlines
and a great new pooling of genes frank
herbert recognized that humanity had
a deep evolutionary desire to mingle and
mix its gene pool
it was a necessity for the survival of
the species
genetic isolation meant stagnation
stagnation meant
death that's lalaksu are an example of a
group of humans who embody this concept
they do not breed or mingle with other
humans eons of genetic isolation has
separated them from other people
and they seem to be on a trajectory for
inhumanity
the tlelaxu are doomed society
ultimately
all of the things mentioned in this
video considered given the history of
manifest destiny
continentalism and the white savior
and given frank herbert's own background
as well as the way the concept of race
is treated in dune
i have to conclude that the dune saga is
in fact
not an example of the white savior trope
the trope is certainly real
and is still prevalent in modern
literature and film
it's rather odd that after so much time
the trope repeatedly appears
and it's important to acknowledge when
it does
thank you guys so much for watching
again if you enjoy my content please
click the like button
and subscribe if you want to see more
videos and guys
i also have a twitter and you can
totally follow me there
please peace out
you